[Music]  my father is not the man I had imagined  he is a monster quite literally and I  must stop him  [Music]  of course to do that I'll nature help to  destroy his secret underground lab  see it easier if Hubertus polish garnet  the college updates and carnies in the  open air  if you can open an alien business  with the carpark and none of the things  open light and boom lights no no he  doesn't deep into the earth below a tube  station to hide his awful work on behind  until he could strike history like a  pole  Knutson special appeal for these dark  spaces TV right and he knew nothing to  something to frighten an irate your  enemy  [Music]  gather your resources and you'll it's a  mutant promote transit station before  this  Scottish twisted creation and starting  to stir  [Music]  please find me before time runs out  [Music]